la plus grande centrale nucléaire
d'europe sous la menace permanente d'une
catastrophe et un quotidien difficile
pour les habitants qui vivent tout près
après les multiples bombardements autour
du site russes et ukrainiens s'accusent
mutuellement d'être à l'origine les
autorités locales ont peu de marge de
manoeuvre à part distribuer des
tablettes diodes par mesure de
précaution pourquoi les sourds on a
acheté les premières doses cet hiver
quand la centrale avaient commencé à
être bombardées
[Musique]
là on est venu en chercher d'autres au
diamant
on en a toujours su renouveler
stop
pour nous a dit que chaque adulte devait
avoir une tablette sur lui j'ai un fils
de 7 ans il lui faudra une demi
tablettes
face au risque d'incident nucléaire le
cren forme des unités spéciales qui
pourront réagir selon un protocole bien
établi
lors de l'entraînement on commence par
mesurer le taux de radiation des
personnes dans un lieu qu'on appelle la
zone sensible où le degré de
contamination est établi ensuite on
effectue un contrôle supplémentaire
après que ces personnes ont été
déplacées dans un autre lieu une fois
que le risque est devenu moins élevé au
cours des dernières 24 heures des
frappes ont visé des zones
résidentielles non loin de zaporizhya le
cren accuse moscou de stocker des armes
lourdes au sein même de la centrale est
d'utiliser le site à des fins militaires
pour attaquer les positions ukrainienne